Chris Brown detained in Paris on
suspicions of rape and alleged drug
related offenses things are at a
standstill for the American singer
according to CBS News French police
officials say Chris and two other people
are in custody in Paris after a 24
year-old woman filed a rape complaint
reports claimed his bodyguard is one of
the others being detained before the
incident Chris was spotted stepping out
for Paris Fashion Week events the
singers camp has yet to respond to these
news reports well guys this isn't the
first time the pop stars had a run-in
with the law
chris has had a history of legal trouble
stemming back a decade Brown was
convicted for the 2009 assault on his
then-girlfriend Rihanna he completed his
probation back in 2015 now in 2013 he
was charged with a misdemeanor assault
and ordered to check into rehab after
striking a man outside a Washington DC
hotel as a result he spent
two-and-a-half months in custody he
caught up with Chris after he faced jail
time where he said he had a very
humbling experience take a look I think
Jim was all I needed man I just see I'll
be honest man being in there you don't
want to ever go back I don't think
anybody anybody that gives you the story
two tough guys it's like he didn't
matter I could go to jail he ain't
tripping they're lying to you they are
but I would just say that was all I
needed man I think sometimes some some
of us need a wake-up call and I think
that was my big one they wanted to
villainize you more than give you a
second chance so what and you convinced
yourself that you could get a second
chance
oh my faith man I think ultimately just
me believing in and the talents I've
been given and gifted you know believing
in my higher power
I'm just really been looking like okay
let's do this man
you know I think the underdog is
something I've been used to being you
know and I always having to prove myself
whether it having to be me as a man me
as an artist me as a performer the
Grammy winners time staying out of
trouble was short-lived and 2016 Brown
was arrested at his Los Angeles home for
an alleged assault with a deadly weapon
after four
beauty queen Bailey Curran called 911
outside his house asking for help last
year he was arrested in Florida after a
concert over an outstanding warrant for
felony battery so if these accusations
are true it's really unfortunate because
Brown appeared to be making a big
comeback in his career he's always
seemed to be a really great dad with
royalty and the R&B singer dropped new
music he's been breaking music chart
records just a lot has been going on and
if you've been on line his undecided
dance challenge went viral
now just one day before reportedly being
detained the 29 year old shared this
snap from the studio captioned dance
rehearsal at dancer Boy Smith got me
working in Paris CBS News reports
Brown's publicist at Sony Music would
not immediately respond to a request for
comment of course we know in recent
weeks Sony just dropped our Kelly after
his allegations so it will be really
interesting to see how this all pans out
for Chris Brown if those allegations end
up being true et has also reached out
for comments so be sure to subscribe to
all things et so you can stay up to date
on the latest until next time I'm at
Kourtney underscore teza know bye for
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]